in light of your unique situation
joining us as a fifth year we've devised
something extraordinary to ensure your
success
a lot to absorb on your first day can't
believe I'm here
Professor Weasley has asked that your
professors give you instruction outside
of the ordinary curriculum
[Music]
much to
you have the benefit of an exceptionally
skilled team of witches and wizards to
guide you
test your abilities both innate and
learn you've done it I am wary of how
much time the new fifth year seems to be
spending away from the castle no need
for theatrics I'm only here for this one
anyway
what do they want with the Hubble
students
I have a rare ability to see Whispers of
ancient Magic
[Music]
it's a powerful magic that should only
be wielded by a select View
[Music]
we're on is terribly dangerous
but I do not know where it leads
I'm afraid you're on Europe
I've ensured that we have a moment to
ourselves
[Music]
let's even hurt shall we
we leave our Legacy in your hands
[Music]